pottsy don't worry about the fact that
this is so long I was really looking for
like if you had a quarter or a fifth of
this answer that was okay the reason why
I answer is so long is it because it
includes basically all the different
possibilities so I just kind of lump
them all together the best way was to
say the fundamental theorem of algebra
and from there if you said anything that
was sort of common sense you were fine
because you knew what you were talking
about most people did not say anything
about the fundamental theorem management
how many roots something is going to
have that was the easiest way and the
quickest looking 12 this one's too much
because it was very well done use the
summit product of roots etc the second
mark was forgetting one of the variables
you were looking for and the last mark
was forgetting both partial fractions
also done pretty well so thumbs up on
that the errors that I saw were mainly
arithmetic errors so I'm rocketed to all
of them you guys are pretty good that
which by the way please make sure you're
advised that before you get into
extension to integration because you'll
need oh okay
question 13 now let me just pause oh no
it's 13 be that on time
I got yet this is fun um first mark for
getting a gradient of a tangent it's a
show question you guys know none of the
parametric equation the on the conic are
on conics are quotable so you had to do
this and the second mark was for using
some kind of point grainy formula they
need to say something like that uh and
getting to the result okay yeah part two
I won't dwell on it you probably feel
bad if you got this one wrong because
basically you didn't know what a
perpendicular was or you do recognize
that that was a different to a normal
normal perpendicular okay a normal is
perpendicular to the tangent at that
point on the graph right whereas a
perpendicular it depends on the features
that are mentioned in this case it was
the y-axis so that's why I know my line
is running in that way okay uh you've
got to get both legs a lot of people
kind of did a poor job of finding what
the links were or didn't reason why they
were what they were two marks show me
show me
right the the mathematics of it's not
difficult
have to reason through it okay 13b take
a deep breath second hold on to your
hats know that drawing up there is my
reminder for myself to look at these
oh sorry hold on a second hmm okay let's
put you pace for a second this is
chocolate fudge chocolate fudge okay
this is caramel fudge this is walnut
fudge with her favorites okay what's my
point
my point is people I know fudge okay
markers know what fudge is when you have
a question have a look at pop a one two
three four part every single one is a
shown result they give it to you you got
a privat okay
the number of marks that people
hemorrhage because they're like I don't
know what I'm doing oh there it is okay
don't think that we don't know her okay
we wrote these questions we recognize
when someone has taken a sound line of
reasoning and they know why something is
equal to what it is okay
I just stopped writing fudge on people's
papers now I will say by the way the
diagrams would fully done fully done and
immediately it's a hard diagram to draw
I'll give you that okay but number one
they were too small number two people
often didn't put this circle on I don't
know how you solved this question
without a picture of the circle on the
diagram which part one doesn't ask for
but once you get to part three why
wouldn't you draw the circle okay the
reasoning is always impossible unless
you have to really saw the diagram okay
let's look at the actual marks when you
get to part one the first marker is for
the gradient the second marker is for
calculating what happens when you
combine them and you need to use that
eccentricity a B results somewhere okay
/ - there are a couple of ways to do
this the quickest way was to use
perpendicular distance formula and I had
to laugh to myself when I was writing
the answers to this solution most people
did not take this part I think one or
two people did but
yeah reasons to do extension - because
where else are you going again
absolutely BAE in your answer well in
context okay so this is the quickest way
this is the quickest way it did take a
little more thought okay more people
went this way which is just to have the
two points do the distance between two
points clearly it's longer but most
people less error-prone and you got the
result okay
part three okay you really needed to
mention the property or the theorem okay
the tangents perpendicular to the radius
at point of contact there are a few
other ways to do this but either when
you did it you didn't provide sufficient
reasoning or you got there but you
spared so much time doing it it cost you
later
and you can tell right so I was looking
for that does the easiest way part four
I've got two completely different ways
of doing this and I'm not gonna run
through them in detail just gonna tell
you what they were the first way the
quickest way was just to work out let me
come back to my diagram we're trying to
find out I will try to show that ah T is
the diameter yeah that's what we want so
I'm looking at this kind of line here
sorry my diagram even as good as it is
is it perfect
that's what I'm looking for the easiest
way is to say okay they're collinear and
then they go through the center that's
all you need that's a diameter okay cuz
aren t by definition up on the
circumference aren t the reason why I
say showing that collinear is really
easy is because they all at the same
x-coordinate so you have the amount of
work you're doing here's the other way
that a lot of people try to show you if
you didn't go that path what you really
need to do was say okay I'm gonna solve
simultaneously between the circle and
the hyperbola there's no other way to
find what aren t are okay then you can
find the coordinates of both points and
then you can make an argument about
angle in a semicircle by talking about
gradient that was fine
the chief way that people tried this
which just was insufficient was making
an argument from distance alone wasn't
enough because if I have a circle and
I've got any two points on the
circumference any two points on the
circumference then you can always say
radius radius but that is
not a diameter people okay so I get that
that was hard to see was especially hard
to see if you didn't have a diagram but
that line of reasoning ended up not
being able to got him any marks because
the argument itself was not sound okay
let's move on to Part C the ellipse this
was kind of patching you most people I
found either really got it or really did
not understand where to go the easiest
way is to say okay look at the form that
the equation is given to you in its in
the form PS plus PS dash right so you've
got you could read off the equation what
the two foci are and the foci are useful
because the center is the midpoint of
those in order to do part two you can
take advantage of the same fact to work
out a and B right because the equation
there tells you what to a is right PS
plus PS dash equals 2a once you've got a
working out B is not hard to find
because you get to use the relationship
with eccentricity and once you've got a
and B you've got your major minor axis
and you can put that onto a diagram okay
is it worth saying you could actually
finagle your way around to try and work
out that that diagram looks like with
that we can't a and B on this right
angled triangle here could help you but
that was a bit harder to see in most
people we tried it didn't work out
part three it was meant to be an easy
mark if you saw okay by inspection it's
in the first quadrant right so there's
your domain okay question 14 let's look
at this rectangular hyperbola here is my
diagram thumbs up for one third of a
page this was very well done you guys
struggled a little bit to try and make
it look right to try and get that
rectangle on there and everything that's
quite difficult but most of you got it
on there it worked
find the coordinates of T and M M
obviously is easy it's just the midpoint
so there was the first mark to find the
quality of T you've got to get the
equations into those tangents which
means you have to derive them because it
hasn't been given to you so the first
mark was for deriving an equation of a
tangent you don't need to do it twice
because it's the same thing
you can just say similarly and they get
you one fork you saw me simultaneously
and that'll give you
coordinates fatigue and obviously will
work that's why the double nose pi/3
okay
now two marks when you have a look at it
the logic is not that hard right because
it's a rectangle and the sides are
perpendicular to the coordinate axes you
can work out the coordinates and the
things you don't know from the corners
and the things you do right come you
back here right what is it you want to
find uh
a and B right a and B in order to get
the x and y coordinates of a and B you
simply mix and match from the
coordinates of M and T do you see the
way that our logic that right so you can
see the way I worked it out was to say
well pastor from the diagram a has the
cordon the x coordinate II and the y
coordinate M you just need to stake that
right some kind of logic if you jump
straight to this is a good chance you
didn't get that mark didn't show you
where it came from
right sure that there on the hyperbola
okay once you've done that you just have
to multiply them together to show that
they satisfy the original equation
BAM they satisfy it it's on the
hyperbola